We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David P.. We talked earlier
in the show about vaccine alarmism, which
is different than anti VAX. Anti vaccine is
also a big problem from the standpoint of
the coronavirus vaccine. Here is a caller
who sounds like he's in a really tough situation
with his parents at home. Take a listen to this.
Hi, David. This is Christian from Baton
Rouge, Louisiana. I was just wondering if
you could speak on the safety of the vaccine,
because my parent, who's a clinical physician,
has pretty much told me that if I
take the vaccine, they will talk to me
why they're so scared of it. And I
mean, practically everyone I know
is not taking the vaccine out of fear that
it's rushed or that it's going to hurt them.
I just I don't see how doctors
can think this and not be sure.
It is very scary that many health care workers,
including doctors and nurses, are uncritically
repeating some of the same debunked derogatory
talking points about the vaccine that people who,
you know, do research by looking at the article
shared by their crazy cousin on Facebook. Every
single one of these claims has been debunked. The
vaccine wasn't rushed. The MRSA based platform for
making vaccines has been in play for more than a
decade at this point. And part of it is that once
you have the platform in place, the individual
vaccine takes far less time to develop. So that's
one piece that's been answered. The question
about vaccine safety there, I actually I have an
exchange with an anti Baxter that I might publish
soon via via email. But one of the talking points
that they talk about is someone died during
vaccine testing. And what they are referring
to is an individual in Brazil who died of covid
complications while part of the vaccine trial.
It was later determined that they were in the
placebo group. That individual did not even
receive the vaccine. Very important to understand.
And then in terms of long term effects, I mean,
listen, we've talked about this before. You
can always say there might be some effect
over a time period that is longer than the time
period the vaccine has been out. If a vaccine
has been out for 20 years, you could always
say we don't know if the vaccine doesn't have
negative long term effects that you only learn
about after 21 years for vaccines. Been out 50
years. You can say, what if the negative effects
start after 51 years? What we do know is that
the negative effects that are known about vaccines
tend to happen within the first couple of weeks,
and that is it. And that historically there
was a vaccine a long time ago that over the
long term increased your risk of being diagnosed
with Guayabera syndrome. And I believe it changed
it from one in two million to one in one million.
That is an old vaccine. I'm going from memory. I
believe it was an early polio vaccine, although
I may be wrong about that. Please don't hold me
to it. And we know a lot about these things. So
it's scary that a doctor is telling their kid,
if you get vaccinated, I won't talk to you.
Unfortunately, the virus of antibiotics has
infected many areas of American society, and
that's a very, very scary thing. But hopefully
antiwar sentiment will decline. It has been
declining. At one point in May of 2020, 60 percent
of the countries said they weren't interested
in the covid vaccine that dropped to 50, 40,
30. Latest numbers I saw are that about a quarter
of the country doesn't want the vaccine and the
number keeps declining with time. That's good. And
hopefully, as vaccine supply becomes available,
vaccine interest will also increase. We've got
a great bonus show for you today. California
is going with their own covid relief package.
Very interesting. We will discuss it. We also have
new obstacles to the confirmation of Joe Biden's
nominee, Neera Tanden. This is a nominee I opposed
from day one. And now it is actually looking
like more and more of an uphill battle for Neera
Tanden. Thanks to a couple of Republicans. That's
a good thing. I'll tell you why. And lastly,
Treasury Secretary Janet Yellen has sounded a.
Warning about bitcoin, we will talk about that
and much more on today's bonus show, get instant
access by becoming a member at Join Pakman Dotcom.